bonjour et bienvenue dans diagonale tv
leçon spécial débutants avec ninon
maisuradze et bonjour ni non oui jours
alors aujourd'hui dans cette leçon nous
allons voir les déplacements élémentaire
de certaines pièces notamment en fait de
trois pièces qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui qui sont la tour le fou et
la dame lesdain voilà alors ce sont
trois pièces importantes elles osent
échec évident on compte toutes les
pièces publiées sont importantes et
c'est pas par hasard qu'on a choisi tour
fou et dames
non on va le voir on va voir pourquoi
pourquoi il faut bien se rappeler ces
trois pièces on doit un petit cousinage
on va voir tout ça avec nos exemples du
jour pour savoir comment ces pièces se
déplace aux échecs tels commençons par
le tour voila voila vous voyez où
maintenant la position donc ici on a un
il faut toujours des rois sur un
échiquier puisque il peut pas y avoir de
position sont les rois puisque les rois
est ce qu'elle est les rois nenê ces
captures pas ou si cela ne dure pas
puisque c'est la pièce fondamentale
quand le roi est capturée c'est la fin
de la partie
alors ici nous avons donc une tour
blanche il ya aucune autre pièce que ça
nous permettra de mieux voir le
déplacement alors comment se déplacent
cette tour donc les tours se déplace sur
les rangées et les colonnes alors
suivront jeu nous a expliqué premier
recours donc c'est à dire verticalement
ou horizontalement donc ici comme ça
voilà pour vous que vous comprenez mieux
alors est-ce que ça peut aller en
arrière aussi oui bien sûr donc plupart
des pièces aux échecs ont aussi à
l'arrière des varennes arrière racontait
comme vous voulez d'ici 6 et aux blancs
de jouer la tour peut aller sur toutes
les cases qui sont marqués en verre par
exemple moi je dire sur la case b4 ici
par exemple venir sur cette case ici qui
est la case e 6
oui ou par exemple sur la case h quatre
possibilités pour nos remarques et on
est pas limité par rapport à distance si
la voix est libre on voulait aller
jusqu'à ce que vous voulez au maximum
par exemple ici oui voilà donc la tohu
est allé jusqu ici donc il sera
différent retenir par aborder placement
des pieds si c'est la différence il ya
les pièces de placer des bornes en
général c'est à dire aux échecs des
germes
il faut connaître et on ne peut pas
sauter sur une autre pièce c'est à dire
dessus on peut pas sauter par dessus
il est catholique il peut le faire mais
ça on a expliqué plus tard donc on va
vous montrer tout à l'air une position
d'exemples où on a montré comment une
espèce fr bloqué affectivement voilà
juste avait d'ailleurs comment une
capture les pieds sont chics
on dit que vous expliquer c'est ça
s'applique à tous les pièces donc par
différents monde est dedans on n'a pas
trop parlé comparer tous les lieux mais
comme vous savez adamence on va sauter
sur une pièce on va cap sur cette pièce
c'est cette manière on saute par-dessus
aux dames effectué aux équipiers s'il y
a pire crise que vous pouvez prendre où
vous allez retirer cette piéce et vous
avez placé autre pièce sur le même
endroit
voilà on verra ça tout à l'heure dans
l'exemple a donc pas son ne mettant pas
d'être sur le fou si vous avez rétabli
le meneur des ailes à tour voilà pour la
tour donc ça vaille c'est facile
entourant le fou alors maintenant le fou
lui il se trimballe comment henninot
donc sur les diagonales
alors donc il peut aller tour toutes ces
cases ici diagonale voilà toutes ces
cases ici donc par exemple on va montrer
des exemples de coups par exemple ce fou
peut très bien aller sur la case à chocs
8 ici il peut aller aussi sur la case
géant où ils peuvent choisir s'est
déplacé avec uniquement sur une seule
case par exemple pourquoi ben sur la
case ici voilà cette case ici donc vous
voyez n'importe où sur le b / diagonale
de même couleur ou vous n'allez pas
c'est si vous êtes placé sur le gaz noir
vous allez continuez vous dirigez sur
les cases noires avec le fou donc à
savoir qu'est-ce qui aurait marqué 2 si
vous vous rappelez de la première cour
le placement des pièces quand on regarde
et vous allez découvrir il ya deux
couleurs de fond sur donc si un éléphant
ou celui des fuites donc là dans cette
position on a en fou qui est placé sur
le t4
vous voyez les notations qui est les
cases noires mais il peut avoir une
foule blanc ou blanc et ça change rien
de ça il va se diriger sur les
diagonales blanc cette fois bien sûr
donc il ya deux fous au départ
effectivement il ya le fou qui est sur
la cas c'est un
si vous vous rappelez le placement des
pièces et le fou qui se trouve au départ
sur la case est fait ici le roi a pris
la place mais au départ de la partie il
y avait un fou ici il a disparu a sans
doute été mangé et bien voyez que celui
ci aurait bougé sur les cases blanches
alors que celui ci mais il était
forcément sur cases noires et ils se
retrouvent ici au centre il a bougé sur
casse noix on nous invite à aller voir
notre premier recours pour réviser le
placement la pièce tout à fait alors on
a vu la tour maintenant la vue le fou
donc on a vu la tour s'est dérangé les
colonnes le fou c'est l'aîné bonal pour
l'instant mystérieux méthode ans la dame
qui est un peu plus technique
oui puisque la dame elle l est encore
plus puissante que les deux pièces la
dame c'est la pièce la plus puissante
aux échecs à retenir ça donc une
castrais précieuse la dame ses
pratiquants est la combinaison de fou et
or voilà fouet tour donc ça veut dire
que la dame se déplace à la fois comme
le fou comme le fou donc sur les
diagonales et à la fois comme la tour
sur les vertes est à la fois comme la
tour donc sur l'on est rangé sur les
colonnes et les ranger regardez toutes
les cases regardez oui la puissance et
d'armes
combien quand il peut prendre un même
temps il peut prendre un coup c'est une
ps remonte qui contrôle tôt donc bon
alors donc exemple de coûts pour les
blancs ici la dame peut très bien venir
sur la case ici j'ai 5
elle peut très bien aussi venir sur la
case b 3 arrêts toutes les possibilités
qui sont offertes par la dame c'est tout
à fait une pièce magnifique qui peut
aller un peu où on veut aller toutes ces
possibilités voilà donc à la fois c'est
pour ça qu'on a mis le déplacement
effectivement de ces trois pièces dans
cette même émission lui non parce que la
dame combine
la puissance du fou à la fois et de la
tour en même temps et donc elle a une
très très grande puissance un très grand
rayonnement sur l'échiquier comme vous
pouvez le constater ici alors qu'en
maintenant on va voir en innu un exemple
qui va nous permettre de synthétiser
l'ensemble de ces mouvements de pièces
mettez ça vous paraît ainsi modifier les
complexes de vue mais vous allez voir
aux aléas et il est facilement
alors on y va tac ici voilà voilà une
position typiques de d'échec si on peut
on doit jouer donc il ya à la fois dame
tour est fou on a mis aussi des pions
c'est pas le sujet de la lotion
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est pour montrer
certaines possibilités donc déjà on vous
rappelle encore une fois donc sur
comment c'est mieux que les pièces
peut-être pour montrer donc aux échecs
vous ne pouvez pas comme on disait
sottero propre pays
on peut pas sauter sur ses propres
pièces donc ça veut dire ce que tu nous
dis non que ce fou ne peut pas venir sur
la case à 4 il peut pas parce qu'il ya
le pion ici ce pion b3 qui le bloque
donc il ne peut pas venir sur cette case
points à 4 donc on va la marquer en
rouge
oui ce qui peut pas maintenant perçu
alors est ce qu'il pourrait venir à la
place du pion b3 non plus alors pourquoi
parce que les pièces ne peut pas prendre
au pied cela va prendre en même temps
donc une seule case et vont pas non plus
place à vous poser sur votre propre
brassard aux avions c'est un peu comme
la guerre ça vous trahison on peut pas
être entre guillemets dessus et ses
propres séries telles quoi ça oui aux
échecs ça n'arrive à cet échec la règle
et est totalement
donc vous pouvez pas vous voir capturer
ou propre pièce ça n'existait pas encore
uniquement les pieds cet adversaire donc
on peut pas non seulement avec le fonds
peut pas évidemment venir sur le cadre
étroit parce qu'il ya un pion de son
propre camp et on peut évidemment pas
passer par dessus non plus on peut
parier sur nicolas seydoux ps sur une
seule case donc alors par contre on va
pouvoir venir sur la case bien on va
pouvoir venir sur la case d1 et toutes
ces cases là alors maintenant il ya la
tour ici j'ai 6 ans lorsque l'âge est le
droit d'aller sur la casse g6 et donc
que la série est notre adversaire genro
paul oui là où vous est donc prendre
capturer les pieds de l'adversaire donc
là je prends la tour lors donc ça c'est
une nouvelle terre aux commandes je vous
disais vous pouvez capturer donc les
pieds adverses et comment vous n'allez
pas aller en capturant sur par exemple 7
mai sur g6 directement donc c'est tout
va disparaître
donc on va voir si la tour et disparaît
ça veut dire quoi vous allez retirer
tout simplement d'échiquier et m à côté
voilà donc là on a pris et vous vous
installez sur la place des sept tours
voilà d'accord donc là on a pris la
toile par contre est ce qu'on a le droit
d'aller sur la case h7 nos pas ce qu'est
la tour plus que toujours on peut pas
sauter non plus les pieds stade heures
soit là donc on peut pas sauter les
pièces que ce soit ses propres pièces ou
les pc nuit on peut pas sauter par
dessus de la cage à sète n'est pas
disponible pour le fou par contre on
peut prendre la tour et donc remplacer
simplement la tour par son propre fous
et voilà comment on prend les pièces aux
échecs comme ça c'était pour le foot il
ya une seule pièce qui peut souhaiter
aux échiquier ça on va voir plus tard
c'est le cavalier comme le chez walt qui
souhaitent mais pour l'instant donc les
déplacements des trois pièces qu'on
vient d'apprendre la dame la tour le fou
lire ces pièces là il peut pas il veut
jamais sauter ni soeur propre prix et ce
n'est celle des adversaires alors
prenons maintenant l'exemple de la tour
de la tour blanche alors comme on a vu
la tour peut se déplacer sur les sur les
rangées alors elle peut aller donc du
coup sûr c'est toutes ces cases là que
se marque envers elle peut aller aussi
sur ces deux quasi si elle ne peut pas
aller par contre voir mais la question
est ce clip est allé sur le plateau roy
non bien sûr c'est à sa propre ville
on peut aller là par contre on peut
aller là on peut aller en f4 f5 pardon
en rêve 6
est-ce qu'on peut aller en f7 oui là
aussi ce sera un capture et mps
adversaires
donc dans ce cas là on prendrait le pion
ici et on remplace le pion tout
simplement par la toux et oui voilà ça
c'est possible
et est ce qu'on a le droit d'aller sur
la case f8 spectateurs à répondre
réfléchissez à niveau mais nous la
réponse est non voilà donc on peut pas
puisqu'on peut pas sauter par dessus le
pion donc voila voila pour la tour
toutes les possibilités qu'elle a
regardé comme les blocs est à la fois
ici par le roi ou la ne peut pas du tout
y aller ici elle peut aller jusqu'aux
pions puisqu'elle peut prendre le pion
mais elle ne peut pas aller sur la quasi
suite puisque il faudrait passer par
dessus le pion et ça c'est totalement
interdit alors reste la dame ici donc
peut-être moule est un outil pour
réfléchir pendant qu'on enlève l'écraser
couleur est est ce que cette dame est
peut être capturée par exemple peut être
vous pouvez déjà commencer à réfléchir
par vous-même cédant peut être capturée
par l'adversaire tu veux dire oui par
exemple et d'élaguer si on restait
cédant fait d'être capturé est ce que
ces attaques et voilà l'horizon voilà
bien d'accord mais on montre est
maintenant on voit qu'ici la dame noire
ici oui pourrait se déplacer comme un
fou et prendre la dame blanche
bon c'est aux blancs de jouer donc on
peut pas le voir mais imaginons que les
blancs jouent un coup c'est tout simple
on va jouer un coup de tous voilà
maintenant les noirs pourrait jouer dame
ici bessette prend la dame ici en d5
encore tout simplement la voile à damas
afin de l'adami sont à retirer donc la
dame de chéquiers et notre dame va
prendre sa place alors on va montrer
pour la dame noire par exemple puisque
on verse un peu les couleurs toutes les
cases où elle peut aller elle peut aller
aussi sur la caste et 6 elle peut aller
sur la casse ces mythes puisqu'elle des
places comme un fou elle peut aller sur
lequel david alors elle peut pas aller
sur la case il est 8 ème fournie sur ces
bien sûr on peut pas aller sur ces 7 non
plus et du coup je peux pas aller non
plus sur ces casa puisque ce faudrait
que je passe par dessus le fou je peux
aller ici je peux aller sur la case à 6
je peux aller sur ces cases ici et je
peux aussi prendre le pion b3 donc c'est
possible d'aller en b3 je peux jouer le
coup mais on peut aller jusqu'au bout
des doigts par exane prend b3 mais je
peux pas aller effectivement sur la case
b2 puisqu'il faudrait que je passe par
dessus le pion ni la case des angles et
des liens fermé donc là on voit bien les
possibilités pour se voyait déjà une
dame qui a entouré de pièces à moins de
puissance comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure
une pièce une dame qui est au centre de
l'échiquier tout comme tout à l'heure
oui aucune pièce à la en rayonnement
terrible alors que là tout de suite bien
et moins de 15 disponibles donc
maintenant c'est vous connaissez déjà de
placement des pieds c'est un petit peu
qu'on les sait comment se déplacent les
dames le fou la tour voyez que dans la
position de départ les pions qui sont
placés juste devant les pieds ça les
dérange ans à l'aise en iran l'espace
c'est pour ça vous allez voir plus tard
quel est le plus souvent on va commencer
le premier co par le pion par le pion
bull pour les laisser ces diagonales
pour les laisser ces écolos
donc je crois qu'on a on a vu dans cette
dans cette émission importante donc le
déplacement de ces trois pièces
importantes que sont le fou la tour et
la dame qui combine les deux donc
éliminé jo qui est une personne ps le
plus puissante des chèques
gardez bien autre dame ne cherchez pas
contre vous expliquer plus tard un petit
peu la valeur des pièces mais déjà vous
pourrez savoir que la danse est la plus
puissante tout à fait la dame la plus
puissante
donc voilà c'est fini pour cette pour
cette courte leçon sur le déplacement de
ces trois pièces fondamentales à
connaître fou tour et dames merci ni
nous pour cette leçon
au revoir et on vous retrouvez donc pour
la suite pour apprendre déplacer le
cavalier le pion bon alors exactement
merci au revoir au roi